I'm buying houses I got I got to get
qualified borrowers I have do all the
renovations it's it's a nightmare you
know and if I you know looking back it's
like okay well then you got to bite the
bullet it's just what you have to do I
didn't want to do that I didn't want to
do it whether it was laziness or I don't
know you know I just thought I'm good at
this I'm going to run I'm just going to
start running a scam I'm going to figure
out how to drive the prices up
buy the houses for 50 record them at
200,000 and then have these synthetic
identities buy all the properties
refinance them pull out the cash make
six months worth of payments let them
all go into foreclosure and that really
really started working well very well I
had one time where I had a guy it was
James red the synthetic I didn't it was
James red and he had bought two or three
houses and there was somebody at the
office who was friends of of somebody
who knew the title company where we were
closing the
loans and he called that her her name
was Mary and said
Mary this guy James red like Cox is
doing something Shady James red doesn't
even exist she goes and looks at the
file her last couple files and and she
realizes of course obviously like this
guy never showed up she remembers Cox
picked up the files like and he's saying
he doesn't exist so she freaks out she
calls the mortgage broker mortgage
broker calls me mortgage broker calls me
up and says listen Mary said she's not
closing the next loan unless James red
shows up and I went wow that's a that's
a tough one and she's like okay so what
do you want to do do you want to go to
another Title Company like we're
supposed to close in like three days two
three days I said well he's going to
have to show up then I said I'm I'll
figure it out like give me a couple days
give let me figure this out and she's
like okay well I don't know how that's
going to happen he doesn't exist keep in
mind at at this point I don't need IDs I
don't need a real ID I mean I I can I
figured out how to kind of make a real
ID right like I could make one I could
take sandpaper and sand off the
information on a regular ID and then I
would print the the corrected
information in reverse on a piece of um
transparency and I would glue it over
there and you could still see the
Holograms and stuff it actually worked
pretty good I don't a cop's not going to
it's not going to pass mustard with a
cop but somebody at the bank like I was
able to go in and I would open a bank
account with
it
well
so one of the things I had done when I
was closing these loans was I would go
online and I
would
pick you have to pick a photo of
somebody right to put on the on the
driver's license right so I'm not making
a fake ID for all these guys because I
don't need a fake ID for all these guys
not with my picture on it but I need a
fake I need I need a copy of an ID but I
need a picture picture where do I get
the picture so I go to Hillsboro
County's arrest website and I would find
people that I knew that had been
arrested and so I found a
guy named uh Eric tamargo who had been
arrested he had like I don't know what
it was the DUI or domestic violence I
forget what it was but there was a
picture of him so I print out the
picture I cut it up I paste it onto uh a
driver's license and I make a copy of it
you know for for James red that's what
I've been giving the title people when I
would close I'd sign all the documents
and I'd leave them that copy so that it
looked like they made a copy for of the
of it and then they would notorized all
the documents even though they'd never
seen this person they have a copy of his
driver's license everything's signed Cox
said he signed it it's good notorized
here's your
check so what I do is I think let me see
if I can get Eric to do this he's been
to I knew he'd been to prison before so
I call up Eric and I remember one of my
buddies like he's never going to do this
and I was like I I think he will I think
he will so and that's how and that's
really that kind of like you think what
do you think no let me try let me call
him I don't know bro like that's the
kind of conversations you're having like
it but really looking back love to hear
the the opener few sentences that you
have with him I got I can tell you
exactly what I said because it's burned
in my mind he comes in so what Eric was
doing at that time he was actually
working for us he worked for somebody
else but periodically we would you know
we' buy a house and we'd call him up
we'd say hey can you your you and your
boss can you guys come over and trim the
Trees of this house trim all the trees
take all the crap in the yard clean it
up they go yeah sure no problem because
that's what he did worked for like a
handyman service so they would come and
they clean it up and they do that so I
said can you come over and he go like
yeah so he comes to the office whatever
a few hours later and I he comes in the
conference room I said hey Eric what's
going on and he says uh he says he you
know how's it going I said yeah I said
um listen I said I I'm I'm I'm going to
tell you something I need a favor he's
like okay cool he's like what is it I
said you know all these houses we've
been having you go and clean up he's
like yeah we had that you painted that
one house you did this yeah yeah yeah I
know I know right so here's what we've
been doing I've been buying these houses
for $50,000 recording them for 200 and
then I have these fake people buy them
and I explain I just lay it out for him
and he's like
wow that's he's like that's bro
that's ingenious man that's some that's
smart like w woo you know I was like
okay yeah I know that's great so here's
the thing I said the title company who's
been closing some of these loans we have
a closing in a couple days she wants
this guy James red to show
up and I need someone to show up as
James red and he goes wow he was who are
you going to get to do that and I was
just thinking just like you're not
understanding I'm not confiding in you
because I need a friend you know so and
I looked at I said well I was thinking
you might do it he was
like CU that's the big favor mhm I said
it is a big favor I could be in a lot of
trouble and I said I I know and he goes
well wait a
minute he goes I can't go he said you
have to give these people a driver's
license you said the driver's license is
you were you you were using mug shots
she you said she's closed a couple of
these she already she's seen this guy's
picture and I go she has seen his
picture I said the thing is for James
red I pulled the mug shot offline of you
when you were arrested a couple years
ago and he jumps up and he goes you
and I oh I said Eric I said
wait a minute I said hold on hold on I
said listen I said I only did that
because I knew if it came down to this
moment you were the only person that I
knew that could pull this off that have
the balls to walk in and do it and he
sat there and he
went yeah you're right you're right and
I mean I I bro I I I couldn't believe he
fell listen this guy would beat the
breakes off me he was he's like 510 5'11
he's boxed he's a big guy yeah so you
know it's like I've weathered that part
of the storm and he sat there and he
goes right right and he goes well I'm
not doing it for free I'm not doing it
for nothing I said no bro of course not
I mean what you know what he like you're
making a lot of money I said well keep
in mind a lot of that money goes back in
the prop property it's not like we're
walking away with you know I think I
said like tens of thousands we're really
walking away with hundreds of thousands
it's not like we're walking away with a
bunch of money or you know it's you know
we got to put up that we got to buy more
properties we got to keep it going we
got to make the payments and I know but
still I could get in a lot of trouble I
said I understand bro I go what do you
want and I remember thinking if he asked
for more than like 10 or 15,000 like
I'll just I'll do it myself we'll just
change title companies and we'll go and
I'll I'll do it myself and he sat there
and he
went I want
$500 and I went $500 listen I almost
started laughing I mean I was like I put
my hand over I was like $500 yeah it's
it's it's going to take you 30 minutes
and he's like he's like I don't care bro
I get in a lot of trouble I was like oh
well yeah I'm not paying you now you got
to sign first and he's like oh you know
I'll sign I'll sign I know you're good
for it I he for 500 bucks I made a fake
ID for him he goes in to the place he
signs James
red comes out what was even you know
what was funny about that was when we
walked into the title company we're
sitting in the in the lobby and Mary
comes walking out she looks at me she
goes Mr Cox I don't know why you're here
she Sayes I told Kelly that was the
broker she goes I I told the broker
that uh I'm not closing Alan unless
unless um James red shows up and Eric
stands up on Q and he goes I'm James red
and she was
like and she goes hold on a second she
runs in the back comes back with a file
opens it up looks at the picture and
she's like oh I'm I'm so sorry uh give
me five minutes I'll I'll uh I've got
the file I prints up the docs he goes in
signs and when we're there she's passing
out the checks 5,000 here 25,000 here
35,000 ,000 here 7,000 here 6,000 here
so he sees all these checks and I'm like
oh I I got that I the construction
company no no no I I have that I'm I'll
take care of that I'll take care of that
so I get all the checks and I leave we
go sit in my Audi and uh he sits down
he's like bro there's a lot of money a
lot of that money goes back in the
properties Eric and he's like ah still
bro and I said um and I counted out 500
bucks but listen a week later we had
another
closing so I he comes in I said hey bro
he hey what's going on and I said uh I
need you to do the the James red thing
he goes yeah I've been thinking about
that I did that way too cheap I said I
get it man well how much do you want
what do you want and I'm thinking if if
it's if it's more than 10 or 15 I'll do
it myself and he sits there and he
goes I want $1,000 I go
$1,000 like oh my God so uh I gave him
$1,000 doll and we he did another one
and uh but by that point it was like
five or six we done five or six with
that guy and after five or six plus the
credit cards plus you know all the other
things like their credit scores start
dropping you know if it was 700 now it's
down to like 600 and at 600 you couldn't
really borrow enough to make it worth it
so like and I have other people in the
wings waiting so um you know we would
just we i' go out and I i' run up the
credit cards and and pull as much money
pull all the money out of the out of the
banks and close the accounts and then
stop paying and you said a lot of people
knew so he was one of the people and
that he was one of the people why do you
think nobody said anything I well I mean
I think everybody was making money the
appraiser at that time I had an
appraiser eventually I ordered the
appraisal software and I just start
doing the appraisal of myself like why
give this guy 500 bucks um so so you
were doing the appraisal yourself bro
I'm how's that possible how's that is
there a check against is there there is
that's funny nobody ever questions that
you actually have to have a license to
get the appraisal software so I get an
appraisers that we're working with I get
her
license and I I I uh create a um an
email address as
her ah so it was a synthetic appraiser
right it was a real person but I end up
ordering the appraisal software by
by um emailing uh it was called Alamo
Alamo appraisal software so uh I end up
emailing them as her and they go well we
can't give you we can't sell you the
software unless we we need a copy of
your license boom here's your license so
I send her the I send uh them the
license and then we paid for it with a
credit card you know you could go get
like a Green Dot card you go put 500
bucks on it or a th000 the software was
like 1,500 bucks or something so you
pick give them like back then you know a
long time ago so 1,500 bucks they mail
it to us and now I've got the software
mhm so so now I can you know I can do
the appraisals myself what stops you
from appraising it not for 200,000 but
even more there's no comparable sales so
no matter what you sent to the bank
they're going to look at it like they're
going to have their appr inhouse
appraiser is going to do a a Desktop
review he's going to go online he's
going to check to make sure all the
appraise all of the comparable sales are
sold for what you said they sold for are
the same square footage were built what
the pictures look like where how far
they are he's going to double check
everything but you know he's some guy
who's on salary and he does you know
whatever 40 or 50 of these a day or
something it doesn't take them long and
so it's cheaper that way where we pay
for the appraiser appraisal the whole
thing got it so everybody's getting paid
right